and finally new rule if Bugsy Siegel
could invent Las Vegas out of a desert
stopover for GIS Amazon can turn
Nebraska into the next Silicon Valley as
as I'm sure you know by now amazon has
scrapped its plans to build a giant
headquarters in New York because the
city balked at giving the richest
company in the world a three billion
dollar tax bribe so Amazon took their
ball and went home which I guess
explains this t-shirt but herein lies a
chance for Amazon to show the world that
a tech company can actually do good we
have a problem in America called spatial
Geographic inequality which means that
the most affluent and educated people
are clustered in just a few cities last
year Hillary Clinton said I won the
places that represent two-thirds of
America's gross domestic product I won
the places that are optimistic diverse
dynamic moving forward yes you did and
maybe that has something to do with why
Trump voters are obsessed with owning
the libs because the libs own everything
else the blue parts of America are
having a big prosperity party while that
big sea of red feels like their
invitation got lost in the mail and they
still use the mail they turn on the TV
and all the shows take place in a few
hip cities there's no Real Housewives of
Toledo or CSI Lubbock
there are no red carpets in Wyoming and
no one ever asks you who are you wearing
because the answer is always target
[Laughter]
there are two Americas and it seems like
one is where all the cool jobs are where
people drive Tesla's and eat artisanal
ice cream we have orchestras and theater
districts and world-class shopping we
have chef Wolfgang Puck they have Chef
Boyardee our roofs have solar panels
theirs have last year's Christmas lights
we've got legal bud they've got bud
[Music]
we have anal bleaching they have
Congressman Steve King
[Applause]
the flyover states have become the
passed over states
that's why red state voters are so
pissed off they don't hate us they want
to be us they want to go to the party
it's like we're the British royal family
and they're making markle's dad how do I
know this because 238 cities and regions
submitted proposals to Amazon for the
company to locate in their area all
desperate for jobs that don't involve
guarding prisoners or murdering chickens
an Amazon picked two places that didn't
need them at all places where prosperity
already was Bezos you're worth 130
billion take one for the team
stop playing cities off against one
another and help a dying one come back
to life
I know this sounds like a pipe dream and
it's true I was smoking a pipe when I
dreamed it but if liberals are serious
about winning elections they have to
start recolonizing the parts of the
country they've abandoned Mississippi is
the poorest state in the country Amazon
can buy the whole state and rename it
I'm a zippy
if we keep leaving the red states behind
they're going to keep getting angrier
and crazier because if you're not
invited to the party an expects thing is
to throw a turd in the punchbowl as
opposed to what happens when Amazon
moves to West Virginia people get better
jobs that don't give them black lung the
locals meet people of different races
and backgrounds and sexual orientations
none of whom kill them they find out
gays don't ruin anyone's marriage but
they do improve the karaoke scene
a yoga studio opens up been an art
gallery a gym that admits women then one
of those trendy bars were inside looks
like the outside
Asians come and open a Chinese
restaurant and then Jews come because
there's a Chinese restaurant and before
you know it there's legal weed and
decent healthcare and the schools are
teaching science again
you